des visages dur effrayant un
enchaînement de personnages des
métaphores animales à travers des
oeuvres réalisées entre 2014 et 2016
samuel gélase dénonce la violence je
rentrais en guadeloupe en 2014 et en
2014 la guadeloupe été le département le
plus violent français donc j'ai été
frappé par cette violence que je voyais
que je côtoyais un petit peu de près et
à partir de cela j
géante a remis en tout cas ça m'a
inspiré pour une bonne série d'oeuvres
des gants des artistes qui s'appelle les
chiens marie le yen en fait donc ils se
donnent des noms d'animaux et je me suis
inspiré des cela je me suis aussi
inspiré des contes cruels antillais une
inspiration qu'il retranscrit dans de
grandes toiles fait à l'acrylique et à
la pierre noire une certaine critique du
monde à travers du pop art que l'on
retrouve dans la deuxième partie de
l'exposition qui elle s'inspire de negri
side un néologisme inventé par un
artiste guadeloupéen
j'ai fait tout un travail en fait sur la
dimension génocidaire de la traite
négrière et toujours en utilisant des
métaphores qui font référence au monde
animal à ce genre de choses qui peuvent
exprimer une certaine humanité
un thème traité par des couleurs chaudes
et des traits fins attirant l'oeil décor
distendu pour exprimer une libération
une émancipation